all right
this is it people it is november
3rd 2020. it's election day in america
the future of the free world is on the
ballot
and everyone's making their choices and
telling everybody all about it
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message and it has all
led to this but before i do anything
else
folks i want to point out that i'm sure
many of you are noticing right now
i'm wearing glasses now
as you know tonight you'll be watching
abc or cbs or nbc or cnn or
msnbc or one of these other clown shows
and a lot of the people on there it's a
little known secret
of the mainstream media a lot of these
people they wear glasses only for effect
in essence obviously there are things
known as contact lenses and most of
these people
have probably fine vision anyway but
they wear glasses so that they can
take them off and feel that they've done
something important or they
put them on when they're reading or they
put them in their mouth
and these are fake glasses and i thought
today
is the type of day because i want to
connect
with you so you see what i did there i
was wearing my glasses and i'm just
talking but i
i really want to talk to you the people
out there
because this is the most important
election
of our time
you see i thought about it i thought
about it and i agree with myself
and then what they do is they put their
glasses back on
and then they read something
biden declared the winner with only one
percent of the precincts reporting
folks this is important stuff all right
so those are my fake glasses i'll be
wearing them on and off throughout the
day
uh because i am an important broadcast
journalist and i'm trying to show you
that these people are all frauds
all right um so before i get to the the
specifics of everything just want to
tell you a little bit about my schedule
tonight
uh real quick i will be on the daily
wire
live i will be in studio with shapiro
and knowles and
jeremy boring and who else i got over
there clavin andrew clavin
and whoever else i think there's going
to be some surprise guests i'm going to
be live in studio with those good people
a little bit later on this evening then
i'm going to come home we may do a quick
live stream in the midst of election
night before anything's known
maybe like a 20 minute or half hour live
stream then i'll be uh
on with glenn beck over at the blaze and
then we will do an extended live stream
tonight where at that point
hopefully hopefully hopefully maybe
perhaps kinda possibly
will have some results uh we'll see
about that but before
i do that i want to talk to you good
people about
second thoughts the board game people
i've got it in my hand right here
second thoughts is this year's new
favorite party game that's sure to be
the hit of your next game night after
election results come in
will it be it'll be more necessary than
ever to connect with family and friends
over some light-hearted fun ain't that
the truth
david and i always host thanksgiving and
this year we're looking forward to
playing second thoughts after a
delicious
turkey dinner hopefully we can get
people in my house during thanksgiving
because gavin newsom
he's not really having it i got to tell
you guys that the game pairs really well
with a good wine or whiskey as well
the play of the game calls for each team
to quickly create a list of words for
their opponents to decipher
leading to hilarious but puzzlement and
laughter simply put it's a classic word
guessing game with a unique twist
that allows players to personalize the
content
with their voluminous sense of word
smithery or just their witty and warped
imaginations
each round of second thoughts is a
hilarious high-speed attempt to stump
the other team
both teams create a list of five things
using the letters revealed from the
color dice be witty and wise but don't
take too long because time is not on
your side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is exactly how much time
your opponents get to guess them
second thoughts the quick thinking
versus fast talking party game
and for the month of november the game
will be on sale at a special price so be
sure to get yours today at second
thoughts the game dot com that's second
thoughts
the game dot com or at your local target
store
and now back to the show
it's election night america are you
ready
democracy it's here in essence we're
having it we're duking it out tonight
okay
so i want to do a couple little things i
want to show you a a joe biden tweet and
a little video that
bernie sanders did yesterday um but but
first let's just
like recap the whole freaking thing it's
on
the ballot right now if we are to
believe that any of this is real and
we're not just
you know in some crazy simulation if we
are to believe
that donald trump and and joe biden are
the republican party and the democratic
party well
this year of all guy of all years it's
like guys
the choice is clear the choice is clear
for any of the things if
if you watch me if you know anything
about my political evolution if you if
you read my book
if you're let's say a disaffected old
school liberal
as as i am or what i would also argue is
just a new school conservative i have no
problem calling myself that
if you're a libertarian if you're
someone that has any
love of america that you're proud of
this place the the 250 years of
incredible freedoms that we've brought
to all of these people
and and we got rid of slavery faster
than any other country
in the history of the world and we
expanded rights for women and gay people
and and everybody and that we've done
this so well and so consistently
and have so much to be proud of here and
we've we've
brought we've done everything because we
brought everybody here and we said do
you have good ideas
do you want to fold into this thing be
part of the melting pot
and and build something great on your
own terms and not have the government or
some giant structure tell you how to
live
all the time and all that which in most
cases
is why your ancestors fled i mean think
about it everybody watching this right
now think about
it whether it's your parents whether
it's you your great-grandparents
generations before that everyone's
lineage
the people that go that came here before
you they came here because they were
leaving
something terrible in most cases giant
government
socialism and communism and and
totalitarian states whether
whether you were leaving cuba or you
were leaving
eastern europe or you were leaving italy
or
ireland why did people come here the
opportunities were
were not there and you came to america
and the streets were lined with gold and
now the gold man is in charge the point
is guys we've done something really
great here and it amazingly
disturbingly seems like it's it's on the
ballot
the ballot that's what's on the ballot
in essence that you
sort of know what trump thinks trump
likes america
he speaks in a funny way it's true and
when he dances to the ymca he can't even
do the ym and the c and the a he can't
even do it he just does this
but beyond that he's done a pretty damn
good job as president
uh the economy before covid was
absolutely blowing up lowest black
unemployment lowest latino unemployment
that peace in the middle east thing
getting rid of regulations
redoing some of our international
treaties that we were always getting
screwed on there's a lot of good here
but but i don't even think it's about
the policies per se
the america that we know that i think
most of us
not i think i know that most of us
love and adore and want to keep going
he's going to keep that thing going
he is going to keep it going and this is
where i'm i'm most
critical of my remaining few liberal
friends
who have spent years you know decrying
and worrying about identity politics and
worrying about
what has happened to the institutions
the new york times and harvard
and all of these places and trump is the
one saving them so as i've been saying
for a couple weeks i think you could
make a strong argument guys
that trump is saving both liberalism
and conservatism and does it seem crazy
that that's the case but yes he's saving
liberalism because he's saving it from
leftism
meaning he got critical race theory out
of our federal institutions he got rid
of title ix which was getting uh just a
due process out of which was
eliminating due process in essence from
from colleges and universities
so he's savoring liberalism in that way
he's not coming for anyone's
freedom of speech right you can trump
can tweet literally anything
and then a million blue czech lefties
can say you're going to be in jail you
should die
you know kathy griffin could have a head
with a bloody trump head and tweet that
out
he's not coming for anything so in
essence he's saving liberalism in that
regard and he's saving conservatism it's
obvious because he's governing
as a conservative and he's putting
conservative judges on that's the
tension
as jordan peterson often talked about
you want the healthy tension between
liberalism and conservatism
i think that's what he is and and if he
disappears if he loses tonight
well then either you just go back to
neutered
flaccid republicans who will never win
but will be sort of liked by the media
you know the media kind of likes george
w
bush now and they are they like the idea
of john mccain now and they love mitt
romney now because their principal but
their principal
because they lose or in george w bush's
case because he's not president anymore
but when they when he was president they
hated him
trump modeled a way to fight back that
that's just the reality
that that i've come to and it's a it's a
weird reality
it has cost me friends it has created
problems
in my family uh i have no doubt that if
trump loses tomorrow i'm gonna have all
sorts of people trying to
destroy me professionally and personally
and everything else
but as i said yesterday i think it's
your it's your duty and responsibility
as a person
and and a free thinker and a human to to
say what you believe and
and proudly support whoever it is you
want to support uh
but but think about it that way it's
like you know if biden wins tomorrow
tomorrow whether or when's tonight
whether it's real or
whether it's just a concoction of the
mainstream media it's like
can't you feel that tomorrow suddenly
every think piece every big media thing
is going to be about
how to how to now eliminate the cancer
that was trump and the
and and the trump supporters like they
they're telling you they want to put
people on lists
they're telling you they want truth and
reconciliation commissions these are all
the things that they would purport to
tell you trump wants to do
but if trump wins tomorrow you think
there's going to be lists do you think
there's going to be commissions about
finding out who the
who the anti-trump people were no the
game will just go on
like the game will just go on so we are
in a
a seriously dangerous spot because one
side
basically wants freedom and one side
basically wants control and those are
very different things and maybe this is
just
this is just the the eternal battle
that humans have to face and and it's a
particularly weird one because
because trump creates a certain set of
emotional situations for people
that that make this one feel feel
seriously bizarre but if you think
that voting for for joe biden means
you're on the side of decency
or being nice or returning to something
i mean first off
on the returning to something because i
think a lot of people think oh
we vote for biden and then that 77 year
old man with dementia
will just return us to the old world and
we've just had it with this thing
so we'll return to the old world the old
world ain't coming back it ain't coming
back
everything that they've sold us is a lie
two weeks to flatten the curb we're now
eight months later the old world
ain't coming back but but there's a
chance if trump wins that we can start
punching back against these people
but if you think joe biden is going to
usher in sort of this i i think a lot of
people think this that
he'll usher in something nice and
non-partisan and be a president for all
people and all of those things
it's like it's just kind of nonsense so
let's throw to this tweet
from joe biden from yesterday and i'll
read the
tweet to you joe biden said and now of
course this isn't joe biden tweeting
this this is just uh you know like a
campaign
person that tweets this can you imagine
joe biden even like opening up a phone
to tweet you can't uh donald trump is
the most corrupt
president in modern history donald trump
is the most racist
president in modern history donald trump
is the worst jobs president in modern
history
why would we give him another four years
all right so let's let's just go through
that
let's just go through that donald trump
is the most corrupt
president in modern history well they
tried to
impeach him because of corruption and
that blew up in their faces by the way
they were trying to do that
just as people were talking about
coronavirus okay
just as people were starting to talk
about kovid so the most corrupt well he
wasn't impeached he's
actually if you think about it what
scandal what real scandal
is his administration involved in right
like there was the fast and the furious
with obama there was benghazi
which was related to hillary clinton and
obama like but even putting those aside
i'm not even making this a tit-for-tat
thing like
how he's the most corrupt in
presidential modern history
okay evidence can i can i have some
evidence you may not like some of the
policies and you may not like the way he
tweets
but corrupt i just don't think it's true
okay donald trump is the most racist
president in modern history now putting
aside that some president's own slaves
but he's saying modern
history and also you have to look at men
and people of their own time so i'm not
implying that george washington or
thomas jefferson were
were racists okay although the left will
gladly do that and they will come to
burn down
monticello jefferson's home and and
washington's home outside of dc there's
just no doubt that they will do that
they want to destroy
everything he's the most racist
president in modern history you know
trump in
january right before kovid was giving
the state of the union
and i've said this a million times but
he talked about lois black unemployment
he has helped start the blexit movement
he has had
tons of black businessmen and rappers
and all sorts of people
come in and say they support him and
what he talks about is success for
everybody
and when he talked about all-time low
black employment the congressional black
caucus and the democrats sat there like
this they couldn't even
they couldn't even applaud low black
unemployment
so racist okay if he's the most racist
president
what law has he tried to pass that is
racist what black person has he tried to
stop from doing
anything he's got this black uh economic
plan now
like he's trying like he's racist okay i
think we can just throw that one away
because that's all you guys usually got
donald trump is the worst jobs president
in modern american history
now we are in the middle of all of these
crazy lockdowns and he is the one that's
been trying to
encourage the states to open up but we
obviously do have an economic problem on
our hand but before
that by lowering taxes and getting
rid of regulation the economy was
exploding absolutely exploding
so we can whittle this down between pre
and post covet or whatever you want to
say on that
but the worst jobs president in history
i just no
no i don't and and when you factor in
all the crazy
um the crazy factors that are that are
going on right now no why would we give
him another four years
well joe i can give a reason to give him
another four years and i can do it in
four words
joe biden and kamala harris what do
these people stand for i mean really try
to think about it
try to what do they stand for we have no
idea at this point what joe biden stands
for right
he kind of ran away from the far left
stuff right i'm not for the
new green deal the green new deal
whatever the hell it is i'm not for that
even though it's on your website you
know and he was always i am the
democratic party so he was always
running away from bernie and all that
but we know
we know that those guys are the future
of the party and that he's just the
the meat sack that they threw up there
to smuggle it in like
anyone you have to have half a brain you
could figure that out
so what does joe biden stand for does he
stand for some sort of old
democratic like obama era something well
that world ain't coming back
that that world ain't coming back and
it's like if all of the things that the
left is telling us about how evil we are
and and how bad capitalism is and all
our systems don't work and the branches
of government are no good and all of
that stuff
well how is it that this man who's been
around for 47 years
in public life and is 77 years old that
how's he going to fix it of course he
ain't he's nothing
joe biden is just nothing he is an
elderly man
with some version of dementia that
they've just thrown up there and what
comes behind him is kamala harris and i
don't know what the hell she is other
than
other than deeply unlikable and that
that evil cackle of a laugh
uh but we talked about her yesterday
with this crazy video that she decided
to put up two or three days before the
election
where she's talking about equity instead
of equality meaning we're going to get
everybody to start at the same place an
impossibility and we're going to get
everybody to end up at the same place
well i guess that means we're all going
to be president tonight
i mean these people are absolutely
ridiculous and and if you think about
any of the things that they say
they're patently ridiculous now i'm
sorry i i don't say that
sitting here i hope you know that i
don't say that sitting here as as some
kind of maga hat
rah-rah republican i don't even consider
myself a republican
but i can tell you that i was extremely
happy to vote for donald trump
when i when i went into that ballot box
he was actually the happiest
and and most affirmed i ever felt when i
when i've walked in and voted for a
president because this is this is the
last chance guys
like if you want all of the things that
have been the bad things over the last
couple years if you want cancel culture
to be emboldened
if you want big tech to be emboldened if
you want the media
the new york times and cnn to be
emboldened and spew more of their
nonsense well then you should vote for
biden and kabbalah that would be the
blue pill like
you just want to swallow it you just
want to be lied to all the time and feel
some sense of false comfort then you
really should vote for them you really
should
and by the way i actually understand
that inclination at some level if you
think
that just being part of the system that
is is
you know the frog or the frog in the
slowly boiling pot but like that's
better than having to deal with reality
on its face like
i get it life's tough you want to go
that way that that's fine
but if you want a chance that maybe
starting tomorrow
we can really start feeling good again
and feeling patriotic again and pushing
to open the country i mean trump in a
second term will feel more emboldened
and and that maybe he'll help clean up
the cities that won't do it
themselves and why is it that it's only
progressive cities
it's only progressive run cities that
are crumbling
new york portland seattle etc you know
this san francisco
los angeles you guys know this there's a
freaking woman
running that was that has been endorsed
by bernie sanders who basically
is is in effect a member of antifa
and she might become the mayor of
portland imagine
living in that city imagine living
in that city that would be a crazy place
to live
you know ironically when i was a kid i
actually wanted to live in portland
because my favorite team was the
portland trailblazers and the basketball
i have behind me
was used in a portland trailblazers
practice
and it's signed by clyde drexer i don't
ever want to go to portland again i've
been there
i've been there i went to their little
micro breweries i was there
that's enough um so you the choice is
clear
but i think a second term of trump where
the media is just
reeling like all of the people who've
got it wrong and the pundits
who've gotten it wrong time and time
again they they'll be scattered
and i don't want to put them in jail i
don't want to put them on lists
or any of those things which they will
would love to do to me and to you
but but their influence will will
decrease
there will be a new world like if you
want a new world
to burst forth that has something to do
with freedom
that has something to do with liberty
pride in america that wants to continue
on the successes that we have right now
remember that piece of the middle east
thing like if you want that
then i just don't see how you don't vote
for trump i just don't see it
or you could be a liberal elitist you
can be a liberal elitist
and the barbarians are at the gate and
there's the guy holding the door
and you're just going to make fun of him
because he's got weird hair and if you
want to do that so you feel good and can
get invited
to new to you know to nice parties and
so be it but as i said i
i had friends before this so whatever
friends i've lost in the midst of this
they weren't the old-timers because i
got those guys it has nothing to do
with politics but if you think i'm wrong
let's say you're watching this and
you're going dave you're wrong you're an
alarmist and it's not true that
joe biden doesn't stand for anything joe
biden stands for a lot he stands for old
school
democratic values and he's going to
stand up
to bernie and the squad well i hate to
tell you but bernie and the squad don't
agree with you
let's go to the videotape so our first
test we made it clear everybody's no
great secret
our first task we got to defeat the
worst president in the modern history
of this country and number two we
organize our people
to make sure that biden becomes the most
progressive president since fdr
that's that's what i'm envisaging
well thanks for saying it bernie the
most progressive president
yeah that's the truth that's what they
want to do
and if you think that whatever is left
of a remotely moderate
democrat whatever is left maybe half a
chuck schumer
i don't know but whoever is left if you
think that they can stop
what what these people who are deeply
anti-american whose values are
antithetical
to american values the kamala harris
video about equity
is the reverse of the american dream
that we will all
end up in the same spot that's communism
that is not capitalism it is not freedom
it is not the pursuit of happiness
or life or liberty it ain't any of that
[ __ ] okay
i mean that was the best [ __ ] i could
mean that was a totally glowing [ __ ]
right there
okay these people they are against these
things ilhan omar
she's a first-generation immigrant into
this country who often talks about
burning down our system
where's your graciousness of being in
this country that has given you so much
that allows
someone who possibly married their
brother it's a little unclear to me
and who has all sorts of campaign
finance stuff going on that the media
refuses to touch
uh from coming here and then as a first
generation immigrant deciding you want
to burn down the system and
just relentlessly talk about how evil we
are like these are not
good people they're not good people
they're certainly not good
representatives
but if you think that joe biden can
stand up to that thing
as if he has the stamina like putting
aside that his ideas are just completely
muddled at this point and it's like
nobody really knows what joe biden
stands for
but if you think he has the stamina to
stand up for it
you know i tweeted out this morning if
you think about it this way maybe this
is a clearer way to do it
how about this for an analogy if you
owned a little restaurant
a little restaurant you had eight tables
in there you could see 20 people
and you had to go away for a month some
family stuff came up you got to go away
and you needed to bring in someone to
manage the restaurant
okay who would be a more competent
manager that when you came back 30 days
from now
the restaurant would still be in order
it would still be there it would still
be functional and
successful and maybe even more
successful really think about it if you
ran this restaurant would you want
donald trump to come in and manage it
manage the employees and manage the
business and look at the books
and figure out how to succeed or do you
want joe biden like it's hard to picture
joe biden literally doing anything
what what could joe biden do what has
joe biden done
i don't know uh all right but let's get
let's just finish this without
without the direct political stuff i i
have sat here for the last couple years
and through interviewing people and
telling you guys what i think
i i guess i've become somebody that a
certain sliver of people
come to for something sensible and i
cherish that and i hold it very dear and
i hope that the things that i've been
talking about will have woken up enough
people right to go from woke to awake as
i always say
vote your conscience if you disagree
with me on all this stuff
vote your conscience vote for biden vote
for a third party whatever it is that
that's just fine and by
the way i sometimes meet people on the
street who actually do agree to disagree
and and that's okay too um and and more
than anything else perhaps
um remember this this feels big
and it is big i'm not i'm not trying to
dampen the importance of what i just
talked about because i do feel like this
the the in many in many ways the fate of
the free world
the fate of free people to live in free
democracies
and free western societies is up for
debate um
but also just remember alongside of that
and it's hard to see sometimes politics
isn't everything
and whatever happens we're going to have
to figure out how to live in a society
with people we disagree with now i know
that people on the right are much more
comfortable that with that idea than
people on the left
and that was always the danger of saying
that everyone you disagree with is a
nazi
because then once you have power what
would you do to the nazis
you could probably figure it out so so
it's not to say we don't have huge
issues
uh but i got to tell you putting putting
all the political stuff aside and that i
am genuinely worried about tonight and
whatever else like
i'm feeling good about life and i think
a lot of you guys are feeling good about
life
when i went to those trump rallies and i
saw these happy people and people that
are waking up and getting engaged and
all of those things like
the game is never over the game is never
over so if you fight for what you fight
for honestly and forthrightly
and all of that stuff even if it ain't
the stuff that i believe and i'll fight
i'll fight with you and i'll play that
game with you so all right guys uh it's
gonna be a long day
obviously uh i'm gonna go do a little
cardio right now
break a little sweat but i will be in
studio with ben shapiro and the daily
wire guys a little later this evening
then i'll be back here for a quick uh a
quick live stream i think
assuming we can work it out that'll be
in the middle before any of the results
are really coming in
then i'll be on with glenn beck over at
the blaze tv and then we'll do an
extended live stream tonight where
either we'll
we'll have results or we won't have
results and everything else oh and i do
want to just say one other thing and
i'll i'll put my glasses on for this
because this is important
um as you're watching things tonight um
be
be aware of the people that
are giving you the news and the news
outlets that you're getting the news
from have they lied to you all along
think about it have they lied to you all
along and should you trust them tonight
we have a major trust factor in this
country right now and that goes to the
war on reality that i've been talking
about for a while
so try to get news from a bunch of
different sources just because someone's
telling it to you
and it fits the narrative perfectly
doesn't mean it's right and
and we shall see we shall see but i
promise you america will be here
tomorrow
either way and so will i oh and actually
i'll be on fox and friends at
uh 7 a.m eastern 4 a.m my time so i'll
be up at 3am either way
so i'll see you later tonight good luck
everybody get out there and vote and if
you're watching internationally or
or wherever you might be if wherever
that is
uh enjoy the show and i hope that some
of the principles that we've talked
about here
make it into your country too because we
still can save this thing so let's see
what happens all right
goodbye